funcom temps de faire en près de 60 ans
de carrière jean claude laur a laissé sa
marque sur les souvenirs
cinématographiques et télévisuelles de
plusieurs générations j'avais envie de
raconter des histoires une histoire qui
était signifiant qe2 significative n'est
à montréal 6 juin 1943 jean claude laur
pour scénaristes son premier film
trouble fête en 1964
il réalise ensuite délivrez nous du mal
parlez-nous d'amour et bingo des longs
métrages à caractère social
dans les années 80 il ajoute à son cv la
réalisation de lance et compte qui
deviendra une télésérie culte chez
michel forget qui l'a côtoyé sur le
plateau de bingo il de lance et compte
ne cache pas sa peine j'étais quelqu'un
fasse shield approche c'est pas
compliqué et je me souviens après des
scènes difficiles grant sydney vais vous
mettre la main sur les épaules ou là
mais
on n'avait pas besoin d'eux dans les
plus sèches et humides le comédien et
marc messier part d'un homme rigoureux
s'inspirant il ya les coupes des acteurs
chez quelqu'un que je respecte beaucoup
qu'on aime beaucoup sont prêts à faire
n'importe quoi pour champions
il a donné une première chance à famille
louzier dans la grenouille et la baleine
et à marina orsini dans lance et compte
j'ai commencé ma carrière a vraiment un
mentor mon mentor j'ai appris mon métier
avec jean-claude
il y aura ensuite jasmin et diva dans
les années 90 puis en 2016 il réalise
des épisodes de la première saison de
district comptait 1 une oeuvre qui
s'étale comme ça sur une cinquantaine
d'années et dont on peut pas dire ah oui
c'est vrai que c'était bien dans les
années j'en dise non par les années 80
c'était extraordinaire dans les années
90 il était à la vente là c'est une
carrière assez étonnante
on sait tous la même chose que les gens
soient intéressés soient touchés par
l'histoire qu'on attend c'est ma
priorité salué pour son oeuvre
cinématographique
il a néanmoins connu une grande carrière
télévisuelle d'ailleurs il a été
récipiendaire du prix guy mauffette en
2017 pour souligner son apport
exceptionnel à la télévision québécoise
[Musique]